a Brooklyn neighborhood is testing one
of the first microgrids in America
Lawrence Orsini founder of lo3 energy
has watched it come to life the Brooklyn
microgrid is our first project
transactive energy project here in
Brooklyn so the idea is that as a
prosumer someone who has generation on
your roof whatever you produce in excess
goes back on to the utility grid so
instead of pretending that the utility
grids a battery
and buying it back later you actually
sell it when you make it to somebody
else in the community gary golden is one
of the sixty prosumers in Brooklyn who
feed energy into the micro grid two
years ago he had solar panels installed
on his roof we talked through a lot of
the trade-offs but came to the
conclusion that we expect energy prices
from a traditional utility model to
increase in the years ahead and that
this investment in a solar rooftop
system would be the the right economic
decision as well as for the environment
to keep track of the energy that Gary
and his neighbors produce and consume
lo3 has built special smart meters using
blockchain technology these devices
collect and process data then they tally
energy use on a mobile app blockchain is
best known for its role in crypto
currencies only in this case the
peer-to-peer transactions involve energy
instead of bitcoins the technology is
key to making the Brooklyn micro grid
operate efficiently aside from the
positive effects the micro grid can have
on the local economy it also provides
additional security during storms and
hurricanes so if another super storm
comes through like Sandy this section of
the grid can actually separate and run
under its own power
so if the grid goes down you have a
place in the community where you
actually have electricity people can go
they can charge their phones they could
have communications they can get a hot
meal the brooklyn micro grid should only
run autonomously in an emergency for now
it runs on the city's infrastructure
while completing final testing
but Lawrence Orsini and his prosumers
are working hard for a brighter future
for energy